our next guest despite playing at the
University of New Mexico our next guest
was a first-round pick in the NFL fans
in Chicago were universally perplexed at
that selection wondering if he was a
safety or a linebacker and do they
really play football at New Mexico Brian
Urlacher garnered eight Pro Bowl
selections with the Bears although many
smart football people still consider
Lance Briggs the better linebacker on
the team nevertheless he was selected
into the Pro Football Hall of Fame in
2018 and neglected to thank the Dan
Patrick show even after everything we've
done for him please welcome the great
Brian Urlacher have you got an
introduction like that before not
recently ok let me get to the important
where you're an NSYNC Backstreet Boy fan
is that true I am I was ok they've
really good songs back in the late 90s
early 2000 ok did you do like the dance
routine oh no I didn't know good sit
down yes sir so I don't stand up and
dance basically let me see pretty show
you can do it you're a linebacker and
you're listening to Backstreet Boys and
NSYNC
I want a linebacker back you know I was
in college right it's like good music oh
ok do you not like them you have a
problem I do have a problem with music
oh what's the music Britney Spears like
that or what do you like know like
Zeppelin and the stone Oh like men like
a beauty ok not gonna be mean to you is
I could be meaning me I'm not gonna stay
before taking the field ok what would
you listen to well that was different
not not in Sinking Backstreet Boys a
little bit of country some
some rock and roll okay with hip-hop
some rap stuff like that okay change it
up what did you listen to before the
Super Bowl obviously not the right I
just mentioned to you what do you
remember about that Super Bowl
I remember Devon returning the opening
kickoff for touchdown then we get the
Colts and third down and Chris Harris
picks off a pass on third and 12 we get
the ball back
they went turn it over and then we just
didn't play good we have 440 yards of
offense to them wasn't good and then we
lost did you talk to Peyton Manning at
all during the game no I mean so they
that's when I were in the lob tempo
still it was hard to even get anything
sometimes between plays you can talk to
guys that wasn't one of those games
because there was no time and they were
doing all the checking in the snap with
two seconds on the play clock and they'd
probably be in the same play they
started in but we just didn't have time
to do any of that when did you know
you're in trouble
defensively I didn't think we're ever in
trouble I mean I
we were down 22:17 with I think six
minutes left in the game and we had the
ball so would you think you're in
trouble with the ball down by five well
Rex Grossman
ah-ah-choo 30 touchdowns that season
yeah no Thomas Jones had 15 her and
yards rushing 49 yards rushing so we
never felt like we were gonna lose a
game and then they had they made a big
play on defense and then it was over and
then the rain rain affected them just as
much as it did you know they didn't
matter we've all had to play in it so it
didn't really matter
we didn't play as good as they did who
was the halftime guest Prince yeah yeah
now did you sneak a pull we didn't say
no we're we didn't say any of it and we
heard I'm leaving here in the locker
room a little bit but it'll have time 40
or 45 minutes long you're sitting there
just you're eating you're trying to say
you know the coaches are making
adjustments but we could hear more and
there which was cool
it was awesome was it oh my god I heard
I've seen it on YouTube I think it might
have been the best halftime show yeah
just because the rain he's doing Purple
Rain and it's raining I know and he just
shredded out
shredded if you were going against Brady
now you played against Brady how many
times three I don't know
so every four years o2o6 ten okay so
three times oh my rookie replayed him as
well I don't know he wasn't starting
then it was like oh I haven't okay so
when your face would you're facing Brady
who's got all this experience you know
and then you got Jared Goff who has very
little experience so as as you as a
linebacker does how does your role
change with somebody who knows all the
answers to the test
yeah and somebody who still learned
they're both really good you know that
the thing about the rams is they're
explosive you know they yeah I'd be
worried more as I Ryan I get more about
girly you know you just try to stop the
run might try and get one-dimensional if
you can make them throw the football but
then you got those damn crossing routes
and the play actions and all the stuff
they do but right you're not gonna trick
Brady and Belichick I mean there's
nothing they haven't seen they're gonna
have an answer for everything you do
it's free there's nothing you could do
what there are things you can do but you
better hope when the ball is snapped
he's gonna know a defense here unless
you get them at the very last second the
flight clock winds down or something and
you sort of trick them you're not gonna
you're not gonna fool him but if you
line up someplace and then right as he
snaps it you run some other place okay
what are the safeties doing so he's not
looking at you probably didn't care
about him in the center applied looking
at the safeties to see where they're
well they're coming down because that
give that's gonna give him most of the
reads of where the Blitz cuz the guys
coming off the edge of safety has to
drop down and cover that guy over here
same way so you got a you know they may
be looking at you but you probably gonna
pop out one of us like can you fool go
off I don't know I mean there's he
probably hasn't seen as many things as
Brady has cuz brace played longer but
it's just so explosive he can try and
blitz somebody can try and do different
things but they're just so explosive on
offense you know you know you better
take your chances and get burned
who's the quarterback that you just went
damn you well Brady's up there I don't
think we'd play well against thumb
Rogers Rogers is good just his mobility
in the pocket and he scrambles to throw
the ball down the field you know he does
run when he has to but his camels will
throw it drew brees it's tough to people
don't realize man so he's not tallest
but people I say he's only six feet only
six feet
he was tough he's he's like Brady he's
like Payton you can't fool him when the
ball is snapped he know
what's going on plus these guys it's not
about a seven-step drop anymore
no balls Brady gets rid of the ball so
fast um doesn't matter how good your
pass rushers are you the balls gone so
you can't get there it's gone under two
seconds what are you gonna do
he's the barest Hall of Fame linebacker
Brian Urlacher I know you're doing some
stuff with United yes on behalf of you
know your lines with Special Olympics
trying to raise some awareness for
people with intellectual situations who
are just have some issues with um so if
I dad with Special Olympics is amazing I
was involved with in my whole career
I left tickets every home game for
Special Olympics did the Polar Plunge
last year but I didn't jump in I was
just cooking hot dogs and stuff for the
participants yeah so I didn't jump in
the lake Monsieur
have you ever done that a Polar Plunge
no Lake Michigan never warms up so it
doesn't count in the summer if you do
but it's super cold very now but yeah
I've been in Lake Michigan was pretty
cold but never like when it's freezing
these guys did it in Minneapolis last
year over seven well for three of us did
the squads one of us did do stepping in
with that visit is it hub dot United yes
okay to learn more about United Airlines
and work with specialized doing some
amazing things you know they're there
educating their employees and how to
deal with people with mental
disabilities just it's amazing what
they've done on all their hubs Chicago's
the main hub yeah I did so it's so it's
home for us
now you accomplished aww obviously a lot
in your career yes and you know you
didn't win the Superbowl but you got
there there's one thing that's coming I
can feel it yeah yeah so there's one
thing that we would like to help you
rectify and maybe cross off you know
you're you're my light rail yeah okay so
let's refresh your memory this happened
and we would like to recreate this to
make it go away
once again that's Tom Brady yeah Brady
right there sorry I loved it Andrew
there's a wanted to put there's a play
my got run over by drawn by studio that
embarrassing is that one maybe we could
show that bus run one more time you know
you met him in the hole yeah we're ready
you know so yeah oh wait but there's
Brady again because I missed a million
times it's to the fact that was third
and six and two players later scored
touchdown best bit pissing me off even
work okay yes and and you're one of the
most athletic people ever play that
position and Brady's the least athletic
who's ever mouth like there okay stowed
them in the category with Michael Vick
Dante : so we thought there you go
oh that Paulie is gonna play the role of
Brady okay and you get a chance to stop
Brady this time
alright so open field this is your good
long Bears fan will say this at your
funeral
okay you know so I'm kind of dropping
back yo I don't wanna get you it again
so John what you're gonna do
I want to get tooth again so I'm not
gonna go for wine going okay here we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's in concussion protocol you're out
six weeks to learn more go to hub dot
United calm to learn more about United
Airlines work special for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]